chickens basically turkeys with eating
disorders we love eating chicken in this
country so much so that we have to
produce a lot of it in the last 25 years
the chicken industry has doubled its
production and headcount from 80 million
chickens a week to now about 160 million
chickens a week a hundred and sixty
million chicks a week
those are Warren Beatty numbers but
those are those are Rob Lowe at the st.
Elmo's fire première partie numbers you
know what those are clean-shaven
Leonardo DiCaprio on a yacht anchored
outside the Cannes Film Festival numbers
that's a lot of chicks
that's an unmanageable amount of chicks
we eat so much chicken it has become our
reference point for what every other
meat tastes like pretty good I'm telling
you man it doesn't taste like lizard it
tastes like made by chicken raccoon is a
delicacy in China I hear it tastes like
chicken you had those with alligator
meat tastes like mmm chicken what does
that taste like um I really hate to say
this it really tastes like chicken
all Medill Oh take some hot chicken
think about that that's amazing there is
no parallel for the other senses if I
said to you everything looks like tables
or everything feels like Koosh balls you
think I was insane now obviously all of
this has been great news for the poultry
industry which is dominated by four
gigantic companies pilgrims Tyson Purdue
and Sanderson farms and I know what
you're thinking you're thinking all this
is just gonna be another story about how
horribly chickens are treated and I know
we do hear about that a lot chickens and
turkeys are arguably the most abused
animals on the face of the planet you
probably have no idea what goes into
making a bucket of KFC chicken
sadly the main ingredient is cruelty
okay Pam look let's be fair there the
main ingredient in KFC chicken is not
cruelty its chicken the only thing we're
cruelty is the main ingredient is child
stars it goes cruelty glitter child and
then statistically chicken and yes
chickens no doubt can be treated
terribly but that is not what this story
is about this is about chicken farmers
and unfortunately this is going to be a
lot less pleasant than what you are
looking at right there poultry companies
would have you believe chicken farmers
have it made smiling in their
promotional videos always no matter the
company over the top of jangly guitar
music it's a good feeling to to have a
flock of birds that are beautiful
healthy you know you've done a good job
the best product that you could produce
has just left your farm if someone
called me up tomorrow and said would you
be a poultry farmer all over again I
would say yes sometimes I don't
understand him as well as I do the
chickens yeah of course you don't your
husband is an adult human with a vibrant
interior life or washing infinite
complexities and that is just a
chicken so yes it's easier to understand
but despite those beautifully produced
testimonials it turns out many farmers
have a very different experience of it
fan of heart attacks since I've been in
the chicken business the struggle has
been very real and there's been lots of
nights that we haven't slept it's kind
of tough now kind of tough it is tough
and it has been tough for a long time
multiple studies have shown that many
growers who sole source of income was
chicken farming live below or near the
poverty line which sounds insane how can
the people who make the meat we eat the
most barely be making a living we eat
chicken when it's been popcorned when
it's been fingered and when it's in
Disney's mouth shaped nuggets which
incidentally is a little legally
suspicious listen there might be Mouse
in these but we technically told you so
you cannot sue this this is all thanks
to a system called contract farming
contract farming is basically chicken
daycare companies bring baby chicks to
an independent farm drop them off and
pick them up little more than a month
later when they're fully grown I'm
assuming that's how daycare works
97% of chickens are raised this way and
when the chicken companies describe it
again over jangly guitars they
make the system sound great for farmers
Tyson Foods actually owns the feed and
the feed bins and we actually own the
chickens in the house however the
properties the equipment the labor
everything around the business on the
farm is actually owned by the farmer
you've gotta hand it to them jangly
guitars simply make anything sound more
plausible here I'll show you give me
some music Mickey Mouse nuggets take the
finest chicken no Mouse and cover it
with breadcrumbs no mouse I'm not it's
are the epitome of Mouse less chicken
one Mouse see what but but think about
what that guy actually just said you own
the property and the equipment we own
the chickens that essentially means you
own everything that costs money and we
own everything that makes money because
typically farmers go into a great deal
of debt just to build chicken houses and
go into the business and the moment you
sign that contract the chicken companies
have a lot of leverage over you so all
those horrible conditions that chickens
are kept in farmers might not care for
those either bound by contract Craig is
not even allowed to give them sunshine
or fresh air if you get that natural
sunlight and the birds will act if they
don't want that they want him sitting
down getting up taking the drink a bite
to eat and sitting back down
he gets fattening oh I absolutely would
do away we saw the walls I would give
them back sunlight letting sunshine and
fresh air in is number one two birds
will love it and number two better for
me
yeah but of course chicken companies
won't let you do that they know that
chickens are like reality stars the
happier they are the less money they're
worth there is there is a reason that II
cancelled keeping up with alan and
arlene older partners and best friends
for 15 years
and it it's not because Allen was too
good a listener and and the problem is
as fast as farmers trying to pay down
their debts companies can pile more on
by demanding that they make expensive
upgrades the company's on a regular
basis come around so all you have to do
this upgrade or that upgrade and if you
don't you know go get chickens anymore
we gotta have this you got to have that
you got to have that you know it started
out first it was nipple drinkers and
then it went to tunnel houses and then
it went to blackout curtains on the
south side and all this more stuff ended
up costing more than our original
buildings and that must be frustrating
farming chickens is like hooking up with
James Franco not James first you wanted
us to try nipple drinkers which was
weird but I put up with it then it was
the tunnel house which was even worse
and now you want us to try blackout
curtains no James no I'm out we're done
James we're done so if you think about
it at this point a farmer may have
borrowed over a million dollars for
houses and improvements but they do this
because they're led to believe that
they'll have a steady source of income
except they're actually paid according
to a tournament or Gladiator system and
unfortunately again it is significantly
less adorable than what you are looking
at right here because watch one business
journalist explain it the company takes
you know could be as many as 100 farmers
in an area and then it ranks them
against one another those in the top
half will get a bonus payment extra
money those in the bottom half will get
a deduction they'll get financially
punished and what that means is that you
are competing against your neighbors if
they produce fatter chickens with less
feed your pay gets cut and not by a
nickel you can be paid nearly half as
much as other growers per pound for
reasons not entirely within your control
it's like an agricultural Glengarry Glen
Ross or hen Gary hen Ross if you
ABC a always BBC clucking do it and look
I do not apologize for that joke I stand
by it I stand by that no no no - you had
your chance here Jimmy get on board and
look losing a tournament and being
labeled a bad grower cannot just cost
farmers their home it can cost them a
lot more
this past Monday morning in North
Carolina one of these bad growers went
out drove down a country road he was
terminated from his contract about to
lose his home took a gun and ended his
life that's what we're talking about
here today this is personal it's gets
real for poultry growers at this point
you might be angry at the chicken
industry but careful you need to leave a
little room cuz you're about to get even
angrier a chicken industry spokesman was
actually asked about why so many farmers
live below the poverty line and this was
his response which poverty line are you
referring to is that a national poverty
line is that a state poverty line
poverty line in Mississippi and Alabama
is different than it is in New York City
what the are you talking about it
doesn't matter the poverty line is like
the age of consent if you find yourself
passing exactly where it is you've
probably already done something very
very wrong and the thing is chicken
farmers can't even complain because one
of the reasons that you've not heard
about this story is that to hear farmers
tell it companies take a hard line with
complainers every time that I've spoke
out against the poacher companies and
the wrongdoings they retaliate by
cutting my pay cutting my chickens back
cutting the quality of my chickens that
I get they're ranked one through ten
number one is the best chicken they got
number 10 suppor chicken coming off
sometimes based on your mouth you'll get
a lot of eight nine and ten tickets holy
when controlling threaten their
dependents with numerically inferior
chicks that's not a responsible business
model
that is entourage that's what that is if
you're ding my band's bra I'll have
every girl in LA avoid you like it's a
king carbohydrates car wait for the
movie I cannot wait for the movie it's
gonna be sick
it's good the boys are back the boys are
back the boys are back and remember if
you're given inferior chicks you are
going to suffer in the tournament and
potentially lose your farm now the
chicken companies claim that they don't
do that although I will note that in
researching this story we've spoken to a
lot of farmers who believe it to be real
and are terrified of it happening to
them a few years ago the Obama
administration tried to address many of
these problems with new regulations they
held town hall meetings and there was
something of a common theme let me say
that numerous growers are not attending
these workshops because of being afraid
of retaliation on them by their
integrator in the last 48 hours we've
had growers have been threatened not to
attend this meeting and not to speak out
I represent or help represent 650
chicken growers in the state Alabama and
I'll be out of all the 650 of them
there's two that was not afraid to come
up here I'm not saying I'm brain I'm
saying I'm not I'm a proud American I'm
a veteran and I need the right to be
able to talk to y'all today but that's
it's an impressive man now if you works
for the chicken industry you would have
to be an idiot to stand up in that room
and try to defend your behavior ladies
and gentlemen I present to you and
idiots five years ago knowing what you
know or at least I think you must have
known why would you get into a business
that you feel least from your comments
that's not a very good business wait why
did you let us you over is not a
defense against King people over it just
isn't
there was a farmer in that very room who
was happy to explain things to him my
comment is directed towards the
gentleman that said she wondered why
Valerie Ruddell got into the business I
can tell you the reason why she got into
it is the company lied when you put
numbers down on a piece of paper to get
the bankers to loan you the money and
then it don't follow through how do you
make bank payments we've heard a lot of
information here today and I really
didn't want to get up here and speak but
we really need these rules and we need
them quick we need rules and we need
them quick you know this guy is serious
because he's talking like someone who
just caught his roommate masturbating in
the living room house meeting house
meeting I know it's just the two of us
but Gregg this needs to stop House
meeting now
strike for Gregg strike four on you
Brett
the good news is protective rules for
poultry farmers did actually get written
the bad news is they are not currently
being enforced because every year since
the rules were written a rider has been
inserted into the agricultural
appropriations bill that explicitly
forbids the USDA from enforcing them and
and in recent years this effort has been
championed by representative Steve
Womack so why does he do this
who knows maybe it's because his home
district is the site of Tyson's world
headquarters or the fact that he's
received tens of thousands of dollars in
campaign contributions from chicken
companies or maybe he is just sexually
attracted to chickens and is jealous
that farmers get to spend so much time
with them I don't know
I'm speculating here the point is he has
thought efforts to protect farmers just
last year representative Marcy Kaptur
attempted to pass an amendment simply
giving farmers protection to speak out
without retaliation that was it and she
made a convincing case the Department of
Agriculture wants to enforce these
regulations so that farmers have
standing and that they don't have their
livelihoods taken away from them simply
because they're allowed to speak about
their conditions what is wrong with that
what is wrong with that and what is
wrong with that is that the companies in
this situation have too much power those
doing the work in these houses don't
have enough power we need to give them
equal standing in the courts and in
their ability to come and see us and
exercise their rights of free speech
please support this amendment that is
that is the kind of speech that normally
has soaring music behind it and proceeds
a come-from-behind victory at the end of
a movie but in real life this is what
happened immediately afterwards please
support this amendment question is on
the Kaptur amendment all in favor say
aye aye all opposed will say no the noes
seem to have it
that is the most depressing ending since
the Sex and the City movie Oh big carry
big you better than that Carrie if
anything you should have ended up with
Aidan yes yes yes I do not boring Carrie
but guess what so are you so are you
Carrie
and look look I know this story has been
depressing and you might be wondering
what you can do I mean you could stop
eating chicken but you're not going to
do that because chicken is delicious I'm
getting hungry just thinking about it
now here hmm delicious it tastes like
armadillo you could say you could say
well I'll vote against Congressman Steve
Womack but you won't because you don't
live there and also for the last two
elections he has had no major opponent
the only small satisfaction I can give
you is letting Sean Connery voice your
feelings about Womack why am I not
surprised you piece of it's a
little bit
a momentary visceral satisfaction but it
doesn't really change anything but the
truth is there is actually a glimmer of
hope that same committee is set to meet
again next month the marcy kaptur
might again try to pass a provision
protecting farmers from retaliation and
if she does then let me use the chicken
companies weapon against them I'm
talking of course about jangly guitar
music to convince you that everything
I'm about to say is true because listen
to this there are 51 voting members on
the committee these are their names and
their States if your representatives
name is up there and they vote against
Marcy captain's amendment it is because
they and I cannot stress this enough our
chicken they chickens that's
what they do every day every which way
and unless they want that chicken girl
able to follow them for the rest of
their lives they won't want to think
extra carefully about which way they are
going to vote because chicken
accusations do not come off a Wikipedia
page easily or if they do they tend to
come right back up because chicken
companies may be able to retaliate
against farmers for speaking out but
they cannot prevent us as one from
screaming chicken at the top of
our lungs if any of these people votes
against the farmers in this tiny tiny
amendment all potential chicken because
here don't be one of them that's all
we're saying that's our show we are off
next week but we'll be back the week
after that good night
you